نحن الان في ناحيه بازار في ولايه كرمان
مراش جنوبيه تركيا هنا كان مركز الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوبيه تركيا وسوريا هنا دمار
كبير لحق بهذه المدينه منذ وصولنا اليها
شاهدنا عشرات المباني المدمره اما بشكل
كامل او بشكل جزئي المباني التي لم تظهر
عليها اثار الدمار هي متصدعه من الداخل
وغدا كثير منها غير صالح للسكنه الان هذا
المبنى المؤلف من ست الطوابق انهار بشكل
كامل على الساكنيه وهنالك
الان فرق الانقاذ تعمل وتبحث عن المفقودين
تحت الانقاض قبل قليل كانوا يتواصلون مع
اشخاص ومع عوائل باكملها موجوده تحت
الانقاض وهم على قيد الحياه والان يعملون
من اجل انقاذهم ومن اجل انتشارهم في
المقابل تم استخراج ايضا العديد من الجثث
ممن لقي من الاشخاص الذين لقوا حتفهم بعد
انهارت هذا البناء
وكذلك في مباني اخرى ايضا يوجد العديد من
الضحايا وايضا العالقين تحت الانقاض لكن
لا ارقام دقيقه عن اعداد الضحايا في هذه
المنطقه نظرا لان الدمار كبير ولان عمليات
ان البحث عن المفقودين ما تزالوا مستمره
تشاهدون المدنيين الاهالي
ممن تضررت منازلهم واصبحوا في الشارع
اصبحوا بلا ماوى التقينا وتحدثنا الى عدد
منهم واخبرونا بان وضع مدينتهم قد اصبح
ماساويا بعد ان حل هذا الدمار الكبير
بمدينتهم وبعد ان خسروا وفقدوا العديد من
ذويهم وياملون بان تتمكن فرق الانقاذ من
اسعاف ومن انتشال العديد من الاشخاص من
تحت الانقاض
عمرو حلبي الجزيره من ناحيه بازارك ولايه
الكرمه مرعش